son lorena vives una neerlandesa como
habíamos adelantado es la ganadora de
esta primera etapa ella ha hecho
historia hoy porque justamente el tour
después de un intento en los años 80 de
hacer un tour de francia femenino ha
regresado hoy con fuerza de la mano de
aso el mismo que organiza el tour de
francia' masculino y lorena vives ha
obtenido ese primer lugar la camiseta
amarilla pero también como ella es una
velocista y está en una etapa de
sprinter se ha llevado también la
camiseta verde también es una nerd la
cndh es a la que lleva el segundo lugar
marian ball la ciclista más premiada del
mundo mucha alegría que los campos
elíseos cuando ellas pasaron muchos
aplausos porque es un verdadero
reconocimiento a la mujer también que
tiene ya un lugar en el ciclismo mundial
con respecto a la sudamericana la cubana
arséne y sierra quedó en el 69 el lugar
a 10 segundos de la ganadora llegó en el
pelotón como también lo hizo la
colombiana paula gaviria en la posición
35 y también a 10 segundos de la
ganadora